people kind of this area here what you
want to rap about palm trees and tikis
thank you very much right yeah pretty
tropical and cool
well someone over there really excited
for that for no reason confusing Wow
palm trees and tikis I like it guys go
into the bathrooms you say yeah cool any
particular aspect of that there anything
cool go into the bathroom palm trees and
tikis back at the room what a wrapper
alcohol is very very what did you say
Mexicans
okay we'll combine it Mexicans and
alcohol it seems I know your racial
stereotypes over here I don't know okay
so go into the bathroom palm trees and
tikis alcohol and Mexicans was it what
twerking and Kanye not everything
doesn't have to be an and in the middle
right I feel I always said this up
that's cool yeah yep twerking and Kanye
T keys and palm trees alcohol and
Mexicans go to the bathroom middle
middle front what you Iraq bow I mean
it's just full conversation going on at
the back over there I think a white boys
about to rap I think he is about to rap
should we leave now nice thing they
block the doors I think I think we
should probably stay yeah we should
probably stay front of the room what you
wanna rap about karaoke do you have a
favorite song you like it karaoke you do
not like karaoke why are you looking to
the woman next to you why are you you
can enjoy things without your partner
giving you approval I mean I used to
enjoy it and then all the joy was taken
do you like karaoke yes okay
you just got kicked under the table
there just like so yes
cool this man loves karaoke so
suggestions palm trees and tikis go into
the bathroom twerking and Kanye Mexicans
and alcohol this man who loves karaoke
that's that's great that's all we need
this is gonna be a freestyle rap that is
a rap made up on the spot based in
Italian those suggestions never been
written down and Boomer Hearst never to
be seen again and do not worry will not
be anywhere near as atrociously bad as
those women we're discussing it would be
so if we can drop that beat my friend
let's do this - be on the sand on the
beach got my hand on a glass and I see
the palm tree is a tiki drink Garrett
comes from Hawaii trader bit trader Mel
yeah they wanna buy me a nice might I
put the pineapple in I like to put a
little bit sugar on the rim never that's
so it doesn't really please your ally my
Tiki drink yeah [ __ ] Madhuri Oh may
with the Keeler down low coming from
that country mehico I see you and not
with an X if you're in what I could
province what happens next you can take
blue agave and when it swells you put in
a little of and make mess out
tequila romesco when will they learn who
won is crystal clear on the others got
all work yeah I will move on you know
I'm gonna slay a drum like a Mexican
cook I'm a traitor
I live in it so the Flies don't get in
it till I am finished next in I am gonna
go berserk I might bend over let my box
light work over to my right who's this
guy I say you call me mr. West is Kanye
see me on the shades
lieutenant I'll phone 10 years ago my
dog Twisted Fantasy and oh no Paul is
out lower the quality he was belong to
Jesus life follow me he did Sunday
service at Coachella who they didn't go
well like who bridge whether still I
like it on the backside claps if I feel
like I need a backside crap Who am I
gonna go you might assume I just hobble
to my left over to the area service
quality
I might be a dreamer so I get away from
the actors the cleaner take it away
waterboy rapid I've got my own beat no
need for your crappy night is okay
though I'll give it a Miss why the men's
time so far away when they piss it
doesn't make sense do they get the drips
on the floor normally retail like the
guy does it go
he'd be like come on guys join my team
we're gonna go and sing words that we
read on the screen
what is it need the orchestra translate
Japanese yeah I'm a smart guy let me
stand up who Barbara Streisand is my son
I choose it from the booth I Spit the
true original spit the real truth I've
always off [ __ ] and I've always off
Bieber husband I've got that guy with me
[Applause]